wie man dinge unsichtbar machen kann wie
ein torwart fast jeden elfmeter pariert
und der erste ebola infizierte in den
usa das sind drei der themen jetzt in
den kriegs von verzeichnissen
ultraschneller nano leser brechen
weltrekord forscher der friedrich
schiller universität in jena und des
imperial college in london ist es
gelungen halbleiter nano leser mit 1000
schaltvorgängen pro sekunde kündigen
damit haben die wissenschaftler einen
neuen weltrekord aufgestellt
die schnelligkeit beziehe sich auf die
geschwindigkeit des an- und abschalten
des lesers und nicht auf die dauer der
laserpulse erklärt professor dr carsten
ronning von der universität jena
während die schnellsten laser
typischerweise einigen nanosekunden für
einen schaltvorgang brauchen dauert eine
schaltung unseres halbleiter nano lesers
weniger als eine pro sekunde und ist
damit 1000 mal kürzer beschreibt der
festkörperphysiker die entwicklung um
diese geschwindigkeit zu erreichen
nutzen die wissenschaftler winzige
drähte aus zinkoxid mit einem
durchmesser von wenigen hundert
nanometern haben die drähte etwa ein
tausendstel des durchmessers eines
menschlichen haares jedem elfmeter
halten
im durchschnitt hält ein tor warten nur
jeden fünften elfmeter die chance den
ball zu halten können durch den
richtigen zuspruch des trainers
allerdings deutlich erhöht werden
wie ein forscherteam um den psychologen
maximilian pelka von der ruhr-uni bochum
herausgefunden hat die studie basiert
auf einer theorie des us-amerikanischen
psychologen etwa tihinens manche
menschen konzentrieren sich auf den
positiven ausgang
sie wollen einen erfolgreichen als
torwart wäre dann also ihr ziel den ball
zu halten
psychologen bezeichnen was als streben
nach promotion andere konzentrieren sich
darauf einen negativen ausgang zu
verhindern
übertragen auf dem torwart bedeutet dass
sie wollen den elfmeter nicht reinlassen
das nennen die psychologen das streben
nach prävention in der studie wurden 18
jugend torhüter aus höheren spielklassen
zunächst in oben genannten gruppen in
diesen gruppen aufgeteilt und darauf
folgten zehn elfmeter auf ihr tor zuvor
wurden sie von ihrem trainer
eingeschworen für eine gruppe der
probanden wurden formulierung gewählt
die auf promotion setzten beispiel du
hältst jeden ball
der andere teil der torwarte wurde auf
prävention angesprochen beispielsweise
du lässt keinen ball rein
das ergebnis zeigt stimmte der fokus des
spielers mit den formulierungen des
trainers über ein war die quote der
gehaltenen elfmeter deutlich höher also
nicht jeden elfmeter kann man halten
aber deutlich mehr unsichtbar werden
forscher der universität von rochester
haben ein neuartiges tagen gerät
entwickelt das dinge unsichtbar macht
dazu nutzen sie einfache linsen die bei
jedem optiker erhältlich sind mit hilfe
von insgesamt vier linsen wird das licht
um den gegenstand der verschwinden soll
herum geleitet so ist es möglich dinge
unsichtbar zu machen
das besondere dabei ist dass der
hintergrund weiterhin sichtbar bleibt
in einem video erklärt der physikstudent
josef scheu der an der entwicklung des
geräts beteiligt war dass die apparatur
noch viel größer werden können und zwar
so groß wie linsen eben produziert
werden können den amerikanischen
wissenschaftlern ist damit der erste
versteck versuch gelungen und mit der
dinge also wirklich dreidimensional und
vor allem dauerhaft unsichtbar gemacht
werden können damit das funktioniert
müssen die linsen in einem exakten
abstand zueinander stehen schreiben die
forscher auf der homepage der
universität zudem könne das gesamte
lichtspektrum damit verhüllt werden bei
anderen geräten dieser art konnten die
wissenschaftler bislang nur ein
teilbereich des lichts verschwinden
lassen neue froscharten entdeckt
forscher haben in panama eine neue
forscher entdeckt mit hilfe von
dna-analysen stellten wissenschaftler
des missionen in tropical research
institute fest dass der frosch zu einer
bislang unbekannten art gehört der
frosch habe orange leuchtenden glatte
haut und seien nur zwölf millimeter groß
also ziemlich klein und dieser folge
forsch unterscheidet sich dort angaben
der forscher von den drei anderen in
panama bekannten arten dieser frosch
gattung gründe dafür sind seine
durchgehend orangefarben und glatte haut
die kleine größe und der einzigartige
warnruf der männchen zur 2011 wurden
exemplare der neuen froschart an
flussufern im distrikt dono so gefunden
die forscher warnen allerdings davor
dass der lebensraum der frösche durch
die abholzung des regenwalds gefährdet
sei erster ebola fall in den usa
erstmals wurde eine ebola infektion in
den usa diagnostiziert das teilte die us
gesundheitsbehörde centers for disease
control and prevention am dienstag mit
die nationalität des patienten ist
bislang nicht bekannt
er hat sie sich wahrscheinlich im
westafrikanischen land liberia mit dem
ebola erreger infiziert und steht jetzt
unter quarantäne
der patient reist sie in die usa um
verwandte zu besuchen sechs tage nach
seinem flug nach texas suchte er einen
arzt auf eine ansteckung weiterer in
kontakt mit dem patienten stehenden
personen seien nicht auszuschließen
sagte cdc leiter thomas frieden
infektionen unter den flugpassagieren
seien aber eher unwahrscheinlich denn
solange ebola infizierte keine symptome
zeigen sind sie kaum oder gar nicht
ansteckend derzeit werden alle menschen
mit denen der patient seit seiner
ankunft in den usa kontakt gehabt hat
ausfindig gemacht und unter beobachtung
gestellt
dabei handelt es sich nur um wenige
personen die meisten davon seien
familien spieler ja in westafrika
entwickelt sich derweil die ebola
epidemie weiterhin dramatisch bis zu
20.000 infektionen pro monat könne es
laut us experten geben die aktuellen
infos zur ebola epidemie gibt es in
diesem video einmal jeglichen täglich
news rund um die wissenschaft gibt es in
der app und block dafür hier klicken und
allerdings zu den themen dieser folge
und zu diesen beiden links also die
gibt's alle in der video beschreibung
und was meint ihr was werden wir alles
machen wenn wir dinge unsichtbar machen
können das finde ich ganz spannend also
diskutiert es wie immer mit mir in den
kommentaren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran